whether it's heat waves in canada storms
in texas or flash floods in indonesia no
country is immune from extreme weather
events fueled by climate change
but not everyone is equally to blame and
not everyone can afford the massive
costs of cleaning up disasters like this
or just as importantly shifting their
economies away from these sorts of
things
and embracing more of these
take africa for instance
as a whole the continent is only
responsible for around three percent of
global greenhouse gases yet it's among
the most vulnerable to the knock-on
effects of climate change take the
cyclones in mozambique or droughts in
ethiopia those types of extreme
incidents can impact food production and
increase the risk of malaria
some argue that wealthy nations
industrialized over the last two
centuries precisely because they were
able to burn fossil fuels like coal
now the goal is to keep these fuel
sources in the ground in an effort to
stop temperatures from rising even more
but what if you need to tap those fossil
fuels to cheaply industrialize your
developing country
while joe biden's doubling of the u.s
climate pledge to 11.4 billion dollars
is a step in the right direction a
global problem needs a global response
and that's what the united nations
framework convention on climate change
wants to solve
how to get rich countries to agree to a
plan to help poor countries pay for
solutions
over a decade ago wealthy countries
promised that by 2020 they would help to
raise a hundred billion dollars a year
for projects to combat climate change in
poor countries
but support was lackluster even before
the pandemic hit and once that took hold
governments worldwide shifted their
focus to emergency response packages to
cope with the shock of the outbreak
another challenging element is that most
of the money raised so far has gone to
green technologies like wind turbines
and solar panels meant to mitigate
climate change but fewer funds have gone
to resilience measures like flood
barriers needed to help countries adapt
to extreme weather
un secretary general antonio guterres
has said adaptation and mitigation money
should be split 50 50. developing
countries have noticed the failure of
rich countries to deliver on their
pledge and the inequality of the
coronavirus vaccine rollout has
heightened tensions without the promised
funding they say they are unable to
announce tougher carbon cutting goals
which are desperately needed to keep
global warming below 1.5 degrees celsius
even if the 100 billion dollar goal is
met the reality is that trillions not
just billions will be needed to pay for
the green transition
[Music]